dr. Forrest Tennant is one of the last
doctors in America willing to treat pain
patients using high doses of opioid
painkillers he operates out of a strip
mall in West Covina California and he's
contacted by patients from all over the
country on a daily basis pleading with
them to treat them because nobody else
will physicians would get these patients
dependent high dosage couldn't manage
them and then they would send them to me
and all that's happened in my clinic is
an escalation of people desiring
treatment for the last 10 years up to
where now we literally shut our phones
off because they're filled by nine
o'clock in the morning but he may be
closing his clinics doors which have
been opened since 1975 in a matter of
months when reason did a story on
tenants clinic in 2017 his patients
spoke of how government restrictions on
opioid use were causing legitimate pain
patients to suffer needlessly doctors
have been closing their doors to chronic
pain patients we're tired of the battle
many of us around the country have
doctors who are being persecuted and
some are literally being prosecuted for
months after we ran that story the DEA
raided Tennant's clinic and home the
search warrant accused him of over
prescribing medication and accepting
payoffs from the pharmaceutical company
insists Tennant has earned speaking fees
from the company as recently as 2015
which he says is standard practice and
his nonprofit clinic regularly operates
at a loss according to financial
statements submitted to the Department
of Justice I'd like to tell you it makes
some money some years it doesn't make
anything in fact we lose I really
believe you saved my son's life when the
DEA raided dr. Tenon's clinic I was
really saddened because I felt that dr.
Tannen always did things the right
Way and I couldn't understand why they
were going after such a renowned pain
doctor what was my reaction when dr.
tenets clinic was raided I think the
government's trying to kill me and every
one of his patients that we have no
place to run
[Music]
the opioid epidemic opioid epidemic with
a lawsuit aimed against five major drug
companies four out of every five new
heroin addicts in the country today
started on prescription opioids off
prescribing incredibly we catch a drug
dealer death penalty politicians and
journalists often tell the story about
greedy pharmaceutical companies that
turn doctors into dealers and patients
into addicts and now we're told tens of
thousands of Americans are dying of
overdoses every year because of
government inaction but if this is truly
an epidemic it appears the diagnosis is
wrong in a few major ways and the cure
prescribed by the government is making
the disease worse when you restrict
access to these drugs because you think
some people might get addicted to them
that hurts lots of innocent people for
21 years journalist Jacob Salaam has
been writing about the suffering caused
by restricting access to pain medication
and his April cover feature for Reason
magazine examines the myths underlying
the government's response to the opioid
overdose problem pain clinics are
swamped by these patients who used to be
treated by other doctors some of these
people can't find treatments some of
them are killing themselves people are
starting to commit suicide at very high
numbers we know that people are going
into withdrawal we know that people are
having heart attacks we know that people
are going out taking anything they can
get their hands on and overdosing one
thing they worried about is trouble with
the Drug Enforcement Administration
which may end up investigating them
because if they look suspicious why do
they look suspicious because they're
treating lots of people in pain people
who may have been treated by other
doctors and end up coming to the one
doctors in the area who's still willing
to treat them and even if he does
everything by the book even if he's very
carefully just throw examinations he has
their records just the numbers that he's
generating and that will look suspicious
to the DEA all of this rhetoric that you
hear from politicians and from the press
saying we have an opioid epidemic in
America because of careless doctors we
are identifying a lot of
that are prescribing incredibly high
numbers it's not starting on our street
corners it's starting in our doctors
offices and hospitals most of the policy
makers have bought into this idea that
we doctors prescribe I hope you in for
our patients who then rapidly become
drug addicts when all of the evidence
suggests that this is not the case
Jeffrey singer is a physician and policy
analyst based in Phoenix Arizona
he is donated to recent foundation the
nonprofit that publishes reason TV
study after study including a recent
study in January from researchers at
Harvard and Johns Hopkins have shown
that patients given opioids for
appropriate reasons have less than one
percent addiction rate in the 70s and
80s and even early 90s we doctors were
way too stingy and we were making
patients suffer needlessly I can
remember countless times when I visit my
post surgical patients and I'd see them
an obvious pain and I'd say have you
taken the morphine that I ordered for
you because you look like you're in pain
and they say no no no I don't want to
get addicted so we have this what's
called Opio phobia on both sides of the
bed but as we started prescribing it
more more opioids became in circulation
singer says it's a myth that most
non-medical users start on pills
prescribed by a doctor the source of
these drugs is often the home medicine
key studies show that many abuse
prescription drugs are obtained from
family and friends including from the
home medicine cabinet the overall
majority of non-medical opioid users
never go to a doctor or never had a
medical encounter that introduced them
to that diversion is the primary route
of opioids to non-medical users which is
why take-back programs exist but the
persistent belief that doctors are
regularly turning patients into opioid
addicts has motivated agencies like the
CDC to set maximum prescription dosage
guidelines which were supposed to be
voluntary I do not know
of physicians who are going to be
willing to prescribe hydros opioids
anymore
I'm not too sure what is doctor Tennant
is doing with me today
but I'm here because I don't want to die
Gary snook began seeing doctor Tennant
more than 10 years ago when his montana
based doctors failed to relieve his
chronic pain resulting from back surgery
complications because almost no other
doctors willing to take Tennant's rare
high-risk patients at their current
dosage levels Tennant has decided to
spend his final few months attempting to
taper his patients down below the CDC
guidelines whatever he's doing I have to
successfully go through it so I can
hopefully have a doctor on the other end
that will tell me there are people who
need those higher dosages they have a
genetic pattern I've done some recent
genetic tests it shows some terrible
genetic variations and I don't know how
those people are ever going to get down
to 90 there has been propaganda and it's
pure propaganda that you can just stop
opioids you don't need a tape room just
stop we're gonna have some patients
commit suicide we're gonna have patients
are gonna have heart attacks doctors in
Montana don't take people like me I
don't have a doctor now and there's no
way that I'm going to be able to keep
living without compassionate care its
marketing operation for the powerful
opioid see Contin hit the US market in
1995 and promptly became the pill of
choice for non-medical street users of
opioids Purdue Pharma the manufacturer
of oxycontin was aware of its popularity
as a street drug a fact it allegedly
worked to conceal yet the company also
created abuse resistant formulations
which are uncrushable and can't be
liquefied by doing so they were able to
extend the drugs patent with
encouragement from the Food and Drug
Administration the company soon made all
its oxycontin pills uncrushable singer
says policies of this sort have profound
unintended consequences
the only thing I've done is just made
non-medical users switch over to
something other than opioids and most of
the time it's been heroin this concept
of abuse deterrent formulations is not
brand new during the days of alcohol
prohibition ethanol was still allowed to
be manufactured for commercial use it
was used in medications for certain
paints for a lot of different
preparations and ethanol got diverted
into the black-market by bootleggers so
the government initially ordered that
the ethanol used for commercial purposes
be what they call denatured with certain
ingredients that would make it
unpalatable but it's hard to stop
determined consumers from getting what
they want people kept drinking the
denatured alcohol so the government went
a step further they actually ordered
poisons added to it we know of at least
10,000 documented deaths from poisoning
from people who drank at ethanol and
Darkly the director for the US Treasury
of that program he said you know if some
people die in order to have a more sober
the alcohol free society then it's the
price worth paying
I don't think for a minute that any of
our policymakers today have that kind of
attitude but if they step back and think
of what they're doing by promoting abuse
deterrent formulations of opioids
they're in effect doing the same thing
that that the alcohol prohibition people
did they're driving people to much more
dangerous deadly substances despite the
government's efforts consumers continue
to drink denatured alcohol often at the
cost of their own lives
likewise opioid users have continued to
consume their drug of choice despite the
government's crackdown on pain pills but
this is the way prohibition works and a
provision makes drug use more dangerous
to the extent that the government had
actually has succeeded in making pain
pills harder to obtain it has pushed
people into a black market where the
risks are much higher the focus on
prescription painkillers is especially
misguided now that the vast majority of
opioid related deaths actually involve
illegally produced
my name is Jillian Monda I'm from
Cleveland I'm 28 years old and I used to
be a drug addict but now I'm not 2013
was a kind of rough year for me I was
sexually assaulted on my birthday I kind
of got a little bit too into just trying
to escape that idea in the first place
roughly four months after I was
assaulted I met my now ex it started
with us just like doing acid all the
time and talking about life and then one
night it was hey do you want to try this
thing it's fun it's not anything like
anybody tells you it is and I believed
him so I tried it I hated it the first
time because I didn't like nodding and
feeling like I was gonna die but the
second time I tried it I really liked it
and it kind of became a weird escape for
me and I feel like I never stopped after
that heroin like oxycontin is an opioid
Salim says that victims of trauma like
Monda or people with mental illnesses
who are self medicating are far more
likely to develop an opioid addiction
than our pain patients who only develop
addiction about 1% of the time it's
appealing to think that you can solve
the problem of opioid related deaths by
focusing on the supply of opioids if
you're interested in reducing addiction
and the problems related to addiction
you have to talk about what are those
factors that make this appealing why
does somebody want to use heroin all day
long heroin is really good at making you
not feel anything at all
it's not necessarily that you're just
feeling really [ __ ] up or really
entertainingly intoxicated it's really
just that if you had any emotions about
anything things you normally care about
and the longer you're on it you just
don't care anymore
I've always kind of had anxiety issues
and I found out that I had
obsessive-compulsive disorder so getting
sexually assaulted I feel like it was
extra hard when you have like your
entire mental health is dependent on
feeling like you're in a hundred percent
control all the time and someone else
takes that control away from you so
instead of dealing with that in therapy
like a healthy adult would have done I
just kind of shoved it down and
pretended it didn't happen and like it
wasn't that big of a deal the one thing
I've realized just between the people
that I was hanging out with people that
I met in rehab the big unifying factor
was that everybody kind of had some kind
of mental problem or thing they were
trying to avoid or an issue that was
kind of plaguing them and rather than
getting proper psychiatric care for that
they were just doing heroin between 2002
and 2013 the number of heroin overdose
deaths nearly quadrupled and they think
it's being caused by a dealer or dealers
who are lacing the drug with an elephant
tranquilizer the frightening rates of
overdoses are fueled by a mix of heroin
and an opioid called fentanyl not only
has the number of heroin-related deaths
gone up dramatically since 2010 but that
increase is much more dramatic than the
increase in heroin users so this
suggests that heroin is getting much
more dangerous and the most obvious
explanation for that is that heroin is
increasingly mixed with fentanyl in the
beginning it started with just hot
pockets of fentanyl like it was just
little bits that were in your rap and
sometimes you would get at just an
entire shot of fentanyl which when the
rest of your batch isn't fentanyl your
body wasn't expecting it or is used to
it so it made it really easy to overdose
but I've gradually it just sort of
shifted into you couldn't even really
get morphine based heroin anymore it was
just everything was all fentanyl it was
all weird colors there was pink stuff it
was purple stuff it was just a really
strange transition into everything being
entirely fentanyl and then house much
stronger could they make the fentanyl
this is what you see when you prohibit
drugs drug traffickers will gravitate
toward more potent forms of the drug
black market drugs were always more
dangerous than legally produced ones in
the same way that black market alcohol
was more dangerous than legally produced
alcohol during alcohol prohibition if
you ask how can we reduce opioid related
deaths there are several strategies that
are very promising they do not rely on
eliminating the supply because that has
proven to be fruitless and
counterproductive for over a century now
cities like San Francisco and Oakland
California are at the forefront of
what's called the harm reduction
movement harm reduction is at its core a
pragmatic sort of way of looking at all
risk-taking behavior access to opioid
agonist treatment like people an orphan
and methadone access to interventions
that are going to reduce harm from
injection like safer injection
facilities syringe exchange James 4mo
runs a syringe access program in San
Francisco which allows heroin users to
turn in dirty needles and get clean ones
in return we're meeting people where
they're at and we're arming them with
information and tools to make better
decisions to stay safe we're also
helping people stay alive long enough to
make the choice to either go into
treatment or stop using altogether you
know it breaks my heart to hear someone
say oh they should just die like they'd
be better off if they were dead because
there would be one less drug addict on
the street and now San Francisco's
Department of Public Health is preparing
to convert some needle exchanges into
safe consumption sites where drug users
can shoot up snort or smoke their drugs
under supervision San Francisco would be
the first American city to allow safe
injection sites but Vancouver has
already allowed the practice for years
and the US Surgeon General recently
announced support for the idea in
America studies of insite the supervised
injection facility in vancouver and they
all find their positive health effects
reduction overdoses people worried that
there would be increasing crime in the
neighborhood that didn't happen either
their good data indicating that
supervised injection facilities save
lives this is one of those instances
like almost all harm reduction
interventions where the problem with
implementation is not lack of evidence
that it works what we are battling is a
moral discomfort and there's an even
more radical approach than that of harm
reduction in response to its own
overdose crisis Portugal decriminalized
all drugs in 2001 they have a rate of
roughly six over those deaths per
million population as opposed to United
States that has a roughly 312 overdose
deaths per million population when you
end prohibition you make it easier for
people to come forth without fear who
want help who wanted to get help with
their habit or their addiction and you
also stop driving people towards
dangerous drugs the DEA investigation of
dr. Tennant is ongoing he's hoping to
find another doctor to take over his
clinic if not he'll close its doors by
the end of June and his patients already
turned away by their hometown doctors
will need to find someone else to care
for them you can't just take somebody
off opioid drugs and throw them to the
street when people get hopeless is when
they think about suicide and so I think
we need to give everybody some hope if
nothing else let them know somebody
cares if you look at the practical
effects of cracking down on opioids the
strategy the government seems to be
pursuing based on the results is what
you might call harm maximization if it
continues to do that to the exclusion of
harm reduction policies you're not going
to see a decrease in opioid related
deaths and in fact they may continue to
go up
[Music]
[Applause]